guys How is the mood
Magnificent
Of course, otherwise
everything will be fine everything is fine
[music]
separately I want to appeal to the heads of
regions, the head of the
agricultural enterprise, as part of the partial
mobilization, is called upon, including
agricultural workers, it is necessary
to support their families I ask you
to pay special attention  I address this issue in
particular
now not only to the
governor who is in touch
taking part in our
work today in our meeting, but in general to
all the governors of Russia to all
leaders
people who are
against the regime
who are not ready to go, they are ready
to fight If there is a war for truth for
war  how is it a war
that
would be fair when you defend
your home it's fair yes you go
you're not afraid when you go
initially the group the war removes to kill
your brother this war is about nothing so
people
leave I didn't get a summons and i didn't
use the army here but  I understand so
that it doesn’t stop anyone now
Well, the wife remained in Russia We arrived at the
tail of the traffic jam 40 hours ago, we stood there and
realized that this was a disastrous business and someone
needed to cross alone and
catch up with the other, she stayed there, I crossed with the child
and now I don’t know how long it
can take  in a week we will reunite if
everything is ok beyond the borders of the lists I
have never seen we just knew
some norms and
theoretically I fit hardly in the first
wave but hardly If you want to get it
was very difficult almost impossible
All roadblocks are blocked
arbitrary checkpoints
trust How  if you want to help somewhere, the
locals spend in the mountains in all
seriousness a day and a half before
[music]
until 28 Yes, we understood that we would not get
through there, it remained there in a traffic jam on the main road to the
border for us about a kilometer
and a half, we understand that we will drive by
car  this is impossible and the servants are coming, something
that starts to let pedestrians in,
so we sell a wheelbarrow, we go on foot, we
reach and find out that men are
already on foot  does not let this action was for 1 hour.
It was a trial one and
then we went and
found a minibus
that sat down and brought us to the border. We
arrived at the Russian border again on foot.
Those who understand what is happening, those who
know what is happening perfectly
understand this will not end in a day
not in a month and this is the second
third wave of mobilization
and we are
not against it for 57 years I want everyone to know that I am
against the war I do not support the Putin regime I do
not support what is happening in
Ukraine I do not support my brother the
murderous war in my wife
Ukrainka's relatives I know  a lot of
good guys Ukrainians I served in the army
we seem to have had a lot of Ukrainians with
whom I keep in touch
This is some kind of nonsense